here in Texas what a what a state  something I love it here something about  this place you guys are just fun I'm a  lefty from New York I fly here I land  the plane I'm like you know what it is  Mr Potato Head [ __ ] you  I don't know what the hell's in the air  here maybe it's covet I don't know but  who the [ __ ] cares  you guys are kooky when you guys opened  up fully even Florida was like damn  that's a crazy state  man oh man it is fun I don't know some  people wear the mask some people don't  though what do you got do you wear it  you know where I don't know what the  deal is wearing a mask in Texas is like  wearing a helmet at a skatepark yeah  you know like what's more important my  health or being called a [ __ ]  foreign  interesting priorities out here  interesting  I wear a mask into a restaurant the  other day some guy's like what the [ __ ]  man that shit's over take that off I'm  like what